today on our show I'm gonna do my top 10
of 2016 10 of them in a row the movie
that I felt like were the best of 2016
get ready for controversy because
another my favorite 10 movies of 2016
today on fat man on Batman welcome to
fat man a Batman Kevin Smith I'm Mark
Barnard just a bet but I kind of a bat
does much it was your bet it's gonna do
maybe
yeah that's cry Megan love like a dummy
I'm sorry who is it how can you just
leave me stand-in if you put a cheeky
making of real quick bat dance dove to
bat ah okay welcome back foul Bevan well
it's a brand new year 2017 it is when
last we left I believe Marc gave you his
top 10 of 26 I did indeed I have now put
together my top 10 of 2016 I've been
waiting with bated breath they're not
going to be necessarily in order that
matters how about just the 10 the 10 of
2016 grandma let you leisure yeah I
don't know if I would put them in a
pecking order necessarily because you
know it's that they all made it on the
list at all is some it's an honor just
to be nominated
top 10 rated the 10 top 10 nice but not
in descending or ascending order in no
particular order okay like the winner's
circle if you get in the circle and your
winner read nothing into this in the
order I read them because it's just that
hazard it's really probably how they
came out that how this list is set whoo
thank you LeBron ha we found it
this list is my favorite ten movies of
2016
from when they came out so chronological
thank you that is the word I'm looking
for but I just take it myself into I
place where I can't remember them
they're at a rich vocabulary stupor
that's a good [ __ ] you could smoke
away the 50 cent words all right here we
go going back to February not
contemporary or was it January thank you
mold is gone ooh-ah Chopin
go ahead now I'm not going to steal your
[ __ ] thunder you couldn't live you
Chad and not at all no I'm a sucker good
tell me if a guy usually so love is you
dog a lot irony
isn't that ironic yeah to thank word
thank you Deadpool what come on movie is
amazing you heard us blow it all year
Sean blows it thank you
small year long you heard us blow this
movie this [ __ ] kid Tim Miller this
wunderkind
twenty seven years old got to be a 18
year old young buck first-time filmmaker
Tim Miller's an amazing job Ryan
Reynolds did an amazing job the
screenwriters did the maze one we score
up for the war like they were a bird
yeah it started functions but it
Directorate yeah we go to Globes you
know it was nominated for a Best Picture
in the musical comedy category we're a
dick hair away from the announcements
for the Academy Awards I'm sure they're
going to get nominated for original
screenplay or adapted screenplay it's
coming from a comic book yeah it would
be adapted either way they get a
nomination I think there's a real shot a
beginning a Best Picture nominees
because they still do ten they still be
ten that would be amazing
could you imagine could you imagine so
good this movie is so you know I have to
tell you we've all seen it but yeah and
it would be the first comic book movie
since a dark night to be nominated for
Best Picture Academy Award look this
country elected Trump please give us
Deadpool secretary please are you
kidding me that'd be amazing okay number
that was next waterish that was the one
I came out in February also coming out
in February and I was about couldn't
believe is on your list of those like
that happened this year
Zootopia yet what a beautiful movie this
movie still makes me cry two of the best
performances all year Jason Bateman was
phenomenal Jennifer Goodwin phenomenal
they came through in those performances
and the [ __ ] cartoons hats off to the
animators the directors the writer is
such a [ __ ] wonderfully human movie
oh I get chills douche chills in my
[ __ ] rectum if thinking about how
much I love Zootopia tell that to a
six-year-old
what to do is to a mom what is the fat
man sick so I'll have to blow it anymore
Zootopia is [ __ ] phenom it's funny
legit funny no arguments here yeah oh
god so good okay
comedy this came out in I got a figure
May Civil War Captain America trace
Civil War what more needs to be said
than that Airport sequence that Marvel
kids I'm not saying anything new here
Marvel knows how to make you feel like
you did when you first read a comic book
if you're old [ __ ] middle-aged men
like us imagine being a kid sitting to
move here and watching [ __ ] ant-man
go to or wherever we press the button is
in the hands to see us press the two of
them yeah whatever [ __ ] were watching
Ant Man become giant man watch him go ho
ho ho ho ho ho hold on come on all of
that was fantastic and it didn't even
get to the [ __ ] non explosive ending
no because I mean again if you're six
years old
you're a little confused by but you know
that it means something you know that
these two guys are going to love each
other and they're punching each other in
the face and you care why and they built
it on the very strong spine of an entire
Marvel Universe that they put together
since then Zemo was your [ __ ] villain
next time maybe I'll put the pink stock
and face on but still it ain't dead yet
oh all of it [ __ ] fantastic man so
Rob Downey jr. like it like the star of
a Captain America movie Chris Evans says
nay my holding his own against Robert
Downey jr. which is [ __ ] tough like
they've turned Captain America into a
grade-a character he was always like you
know hey it's gotten America but who
read it you would read Captain America
now man shape that back to Abu Baker
probably yep am i right absolutely
but oh my god in the movies they've
turned
they're Superman marvel he's and he's
like you don't just tolerate him anymore
like yeah well he better be there's
Captain America now you're like I look
forward to the next kind of American
movie turns out next Captain America
movie was almost an Avengers movie it
basically was you know I'm and you're
2.5 it was Marvel just keeps giving it
to us and I take all my money they could
charge you triple if they charged for
the quality of the movie they charge me
400 bucks I would [ __ ] their that movie
but 10 bucks 10 Bolton spend samolians
next up I don't know if it came out I
know this came out and I think it came
out make nobody else seem that big this
movie as much as I did the nice guy
maybe one board shame black movie with
Ryan Gosling and and Russell Crowe so
[ __ ] good you got to remember this
guy that not only made Iron Man 3 and
way back in the day created Lethal
Weapon he was the writer of Lethal
Weapon
and last voice cow and and [ __ ] long
kissed American night and oh the list
goes on
Kiss Kiss Bang Bang there's only four
words I got to sell you on nice guys
Kiss Kiss Bang Bang almost takes place
in the same universe seventies period
piece makes me so happy
Ryan Gosling is hysterical in the
[ __ ] movie legit funny that counts
for something in my world there's funny
like oh that's funny
and then there's legit funny where like
you rewind something and laugh out loud
and that's me somebody who like thinks
she's funny for a living and [ __ ] so if
that makes if I see something I'm like
that's [ __ ] hysterical he did a 1
like an Abbott and Costello kind of
spit-take you next to a dead body in a
scene spoilers that was just flat-out
phenomenal he's so least funny that guy
in like a physical humor very physical
humor um it's a good [ __ ] flick man I
really enjoyed the [ __ ] out of it
I've watched at least five times Wow
good flick Shane black man you take a
[ __ ] wrong he's goddamn genius
Iron Man 3 was kind of like kiss kiss
Clank lying to some effects if you saw I
love the nice guys check out the nice
guys if you have
ryan gosling is [ __ ] phenomenal in it
as phenomenal as everybody's like he's
phenomenal in la-la-land
and he is let's be honest he's equally
in my money as phenomenal in the nice
guys no kanata show a party and get the
dance as much but you gonna scream like
a gorilla [ __ ] funny
why yeah he does that beggar girl the
screen I'm telling he's funny it's a
funny movie and he's really funny
all right uh infiltrator anybody see
this movie yeah tell me by the
infiltrate with with Bryan Cranston I
remember it exists now [ __ ] I be with a
TR once a year it's a it's a it's a
really enjoyable flick I saw a month ago
and it's certainly not getting any Oscar
buzz but of all the movies I look back
over all the movies that I saw this year
and 2016 the past infiltrator popped on
my list it's nothing that'll make you
yes yes yeah I get that right yeah you
did have to sit there and it's been a
few months but then you're absolutely
right
I'm good Fleck about a guy who's an
undercover agent who has to he bus goes
and onion becomes an infiltrator and
stuff and you know Bryan Cranston can't
go wrong watch him doing it you know
what I'm saying and so I enjoyed I put
on my list
I forget who directed it ranked ranch
has never been bad in anything
yeahbsolutely movie even in Breaking Bad
which had the board bad in know yes he
is good pretty bad was pretty good uh it
was was just on the shake my business
corny in line
well I don't work for the LA time like
one uh uh infiltrator okay next up
Doctor Strange doc strange doc strange a
wonderful movie Scott uh Eric direction
who Leah I add on spooky makers long
time ago lovely [ __ ] dude man
helluva ala filmmaker did the The
Exorcism of Emily Rose in sinister he
did that anything worked big-budget he
did The Day the Earth Stood Still
working kyani's but this movie is just
magic and I'm not even trying to be
[ __ ] funny and [ __ ] but of you what I
was ah it is it's just dynamite and it
continues Marvel's [ __ ] you know
killer streak where you're like even
they can't even [ __ ] up Doctor Strange
crazy man added [ __ ] to this movie as a
Marvel purist I should be like sling
ring sling this but instead I was just
like that's what significant go [ __ ]
sling ring it falls off you gotta put it
back on laney way to match whatever [ __ ]
like I was so on board the cape dazzled
me like you know to [ __ ] his
relationship with the cave indicate the
insentient and stuff the eye and just
hearing
[ __ ] it all dude hearing Dormammu you
pronounced you know I'd always said dorm
the loop hearing it pronounced
officially that comes with Marvel
powers-that-be
Dormammu and having Dormammu be a
[ __ ] legit part of the movie and not
just like the
Dormammu is coming and they showed him
and it kind of looked like Dormammu like
Ripley faces everything it was all of it
was fantastic I think that movie wins an
Oscar
I honestly for what special effect set
up again anything this is cool [ __ ] and
I leave it up against the other mob
family there was a lot of conception
life yeah
totally work it wasn't like this is
boring it was like oh [ __ ] we had last
sequence where they're spooling time
backwards yeah Hong Kong back together
again
oh it's your mom oh yeah we're not even
I wanna see you're still in the Hong
Kong Street but instead of everything
falling apart everything is coming back
together again
and then they're still fighting and
running on that [ __ ] which animate we
want to see that movie yeah it's barely
well that apparently is how the Ducks
have got the job it was like the finale
of this movie we'll be putting the u.s.
back together again that's supposed to
destroy that was a pitch I mean I was
ass [ __ ]
this is why I don't work the big leagues
I don't ever have anything it's
political at all you kidding me like I
was ready to finance that movie and I'd
seen it already I don't even own it I
was ready to finance I will give you
$600 good pitch well done Scott so that
movies on my list man one of the best
moments 2016 and if everybody's like
tomorrow you're [ __ ] stuck and barbels
dick
go [ __ ] yourself I like this this movie
is my these does my list it's not like
I'm not saying if you don't abide by
this you're [ __ ] dumb this is the
[ __ ] I like and also let's be clear [ __ ]
subjective what have we gotten out of
[ __ ] normal today
yeah Anjali yes [ __ ] you know I think
don't like move on they don't even
[ __ ] letting it go in your mouth
like we're holding that for someone
that's worthy they're not worthy
you'll be prettier yeah way prettier
than you yeah well you Jana so my work
here was do I'm not getting anything out
of it look I sucked a dick anybody that
[ __ ] does something makes me happy
that simple doing out of love take that
out of context second dick outta love
you guys
wonderful movie I saw in the theaters on
40x you [ __ ] magical experience
there's snow when it snow you know much
other things just [ __ ] use cool but
that didn't even like the movie by
itself is just cool [ __ ] it's good
time a little bit mom if you betcha
next up for me is arrival whoo
[ __ ] movie I maintain that this
better win screenplay that was exactly
adapted yeah so it's up again maybe
Deadpool maybe they pull up against moon
like some like to desert someone from a
play okay
like it'd be tough to be yeah arrival
[ __ ] do so good one of the greatest
screenplays ever shot and I think that
director Demi then you you you is it
fantastic genius like I've loved every
movie he's made so far this though is
you know a quantum leap forward and
that's not saying he wasn't idiot before
now he's a good guy it's just like this
next level [ __ ] this is a beautiful
beautiful movie that they give you
everything they said they're gonna be in
the trailer it is an alien movie like
aliens gun earth that's life is so much
more and you're so delighted at the end
of the day that it's not just a simple
like aliens are here and weird shits
what do we do
it's a movie that when I was finished
watching I had to go back and start
watching it again right from the talk
because I'm like that's incredible yeah
it's imaginary Oh an utter magical
beautiful match yeah and like you can
see literally as Doug confession when
you watch it a second time you can see
all the pieces moving you all the things
they're doing but it's done so [ __ ]
well sad too
there's one of the saddest endings in a
movie this year but not these status mmm
a lot of that is that very memorable
wanting a little movie beautiful little
movie about the importance of
communication essentially knowing how to
communicate even with things that don't
speak your language the only way they
could save the world is by learning a
language this is a movie that like
prizes yeah most alien movies like we
got blown out of the sky strike
our god you say this is a movie where
it's just like I have to learn a
language or up the whole world's gonna
die one day yeah like there's a red [ __ ]
reward
there's the shitty after-school special
version of this where it's just the key
to saving the world is learning how to
talk to each other learning how to
empathize with each other learning how
to share with each other like the
lessons are very basic but it's done in
such a way feel like yeah like Zootopia
you know like there's a sample lessons
in Zootopia but you're happy that
they're they're like oh my god somebody
bothered in this [ __ ] inter camera
which we're all gonna go see anyway it's
[ __ ] Disney and so I can do like did
bitter [ __ ] go but they put something
that little extra memory like oh [ __ ]
I'm gonna give the [ __ ] yeah the work
and Pixar level [ __ ] even though this
wasn't Pixar movie by their first 10
minutes reminded me of up what of a
rival yeah be like oh we're going to see
the story of this little life and this
tragedy in this little life yes and it's
going to start happy and it's gonna
start fun and I'm going to be like
playing in the wilderness and smiles and
chipper have no idea where you are for
most of you yeah and then you just like
oh [ __ ] and then a certain point things
start going what do what do you like no
now Santa yeah fantastic filmmaking ah
next up let's see and you know I'll save
I will kind of shift these around okay
you know just because they all kind of
come out on the same time but let me
even throw a little love to a movie that
I like I'll be honest with you I
wouldn't imagine and make my list hmm
but it does make the list because it was
one of the most enjoyable movies I saw
you're tripping mmm kept my attention
great performances across the board
nobody else seems give a [ __ ] got no
awards love and didn't do much of the
box office but Patriot today you'd like
the Patriots I really did do I think
Peter Berg's a strong director like he
did remember he did fraud in that line
he's not football and he did like the
oil rig movie deporting rise which I
wouldn't watched him
but I got not for nothing but like this
oil rig movies not my thing
you know although there's always 12 in
the year and I skip them up you watch
the [ __ ] out of you [ __ ] I know you did
don't they have aliens of disorder or
whatever [ __ ] I've been all over it
whatever was in regardless I think Peter
Berg's great director
there was another movie did lone
survivor oh that was insane Mark
Wahlberg now I see that yeah but ah what
did I see other than Friday Night Lights
the superhero movie don't you think up
you did hang [ __ ] but that's not why I
put them on the list you did something
out other than the football movie where
I was like this guy's good the rundown
Sean one sky and on moving I'm missing
one Andrew look up real quick
there's one obvious glaring one I'm
leaving out but Peter Berg is a pretty
[ __ ] dope filmmaker man and Patriots
Day is about events that literally just
happened almost a minute ago two years
ago and I thought like you know you may
have learned from this movie man like
this just happened
there's stuff I didn't know that they
covered it's a beautiful Boston movie
like you know everybody
Boston's real romanticized city and
whatnot and we love Boston the movie is
no different because they show the like
Boston after and I need you remember it
because it was happening on Twitter you
could see it was a great representation
of the city and its people and how
quickly they all acted together and
brought you know zarnov I don't know I
mean the two boys in well one boy in the
be a day but great flick like I really
couldn't believe how engrossed I was all
done oh wait collateral that which is no
very bad things that's the hooker movie
right yeah collateral is Michael Mann
yeah that's right collaterals Michael
Mann I don't know a movie but Hoover IDO
moves but wait there was another one
with everything very bad things is
but Kingdom that is his right and I like
that movie a lot Jimmy Fox and it also
has a Jason Bateman mm-hmm as you took
it exam of Jason Bateman Marc I think
I've ever since going back to Silver
Spoons
when he was granted a record and then he
had his own show if you were moving even
when st. character but totally won and
then he went away for like a while he
was the G most - even Benny like one
lived a real life and then always I rode
up yeah and then [ __ ] Arrested
Development brought back but I'm a mark
for [ __ ] Jason Bateman so the kingdom
he's wonderful in that Garner's in that
who else is in the kingdom that's a good
Ridge and Fox with the lead I'm telling
you man like Peter Berg's it he's the
real deal he's really good director I
think I think he my own personal I was
like a sheikh he doesn't get the sort of
hosannas as you would think a person
like yeah yeah no he feels like what
used to be called a workman director
like what you do comes in make some
really good ways like to movies this
year like just making movies and make
Mark Wahlberg Omega Mark Wahlberg movies
he in the morgue Wahlburgers in the
business this was honestly like my
favorite Mark Wahlberg movie sense or my
favorite Mark Wahlberg appearance in a
movie since the department knew he's
eased like enjoyably wonderful in this
movie i'm playing real close to home
looks paunchy as well Giggy if I in a
runaway to copy a was supposed to let me
borrow the role wonderful flick go check
it out man like it made it my top 10 go
figure
okay robe one what's this picture that
movie uh that came hey road one we blown
this movie we did an hour-and-a-half
show blowing this movie so if you want
to know my feelings on road one jump
back and re-watch that but rogue one is
I've watched it a few times
holds up insanely entertaining movie
watch it was my wife and she loved it
yeah she was before yeah and she
wouldn't go see in the theater or
anything like that they said an Oscar
screener and after Carrie Fisher passed
away we she was like I want to watch
Star Wars she's real upset
like bull can I convince you to watch
rogue one into star ruse the twofer and
so she was like you know she died here
in the sweet spot
she loved the mati she's a tough [ __ ]
customer she's like oh my god this is
fun
so Gareth what's the same beverage
Edwards and n Co because there was a
real movie by committee we've learned
wonderful wonderful stuff Roblin and
then finally of course my last movie
although before I revealed my last boo
you know I will do a honorable mention
okay I thought yo goes I really liked it
did you look dude that movie was made
for an audience of one and so I saw it
and I liked it it makes my list by bald
I put it in my top back okay give an
honorable mention otherwise I'm gonna
deal Ajith amide with us my list on he
like yoga but I did I really like your
grocers I know nobody else did but I
felt good like I will say I had one of
my favorite times movie going this year
watching your colleges in Indianapolis
sitting next to Harley who was cringing
I didn't do papa
I did indeed mob gun he's like I hate
when my dad saw some jokes
oh [ __ ] about my mom all right that was
my honorable mention not now and this
doesn't make it my number one but just
it's the last one what it is a god it's
hard it's hard I know what it is because
I can and I don't I can't don't know if
I'm like this was my favorite movie here
but I will say this it may be my
favorite last [ __ ] ten minutes of a
movie around here and that's tough
because robe one's Darth Vader appearing
mmm magical minute of cinema but
la-la-land
by Damien Chazelle is as good as you
purred it is beautiful beautiful
storytelling about falling in love if
you liked or tolerated chasing amy this
is like a thousand times better than
that with music
and dancing and inventive camerawork and
it's beautiful as everything movies are
supposed to be
it's magical it takes you on a journey
and it has if you're if you don't all or
at least roll up [ __ ] tear but I was
just like like wailing if you don't roll
in tears you're in the last ten minutes
of the movie then you are [ __ ]
replicant my friend like it is insanely
emotional and the whole journey you go
on to have it brought full circle the
way they do is it's breathtaking
it's a [ __ ] magic act and I wanted to
just find Damien Chazelle and beat it
[ __ ] out of them for that ending and and
then argument and love them and then hit
him some more and then kiss them and
blow a little tell me but finales George
oh my god it I I don't think I've been
that mad or emotionally invested in a
movie in a long time where I was wrapped
for the rest of the night and just like
magic
oh what true love and oh my god God's
not taking I'm telling you man like you
know what it was it was like payback for
all those people like what happens to
Holden and Elissa at the end of change
and Xavier gets back together and I'm
like well if you're you know if you're a
romantic yes but if you're a realist no
this movie like was just to have a cake
and eat it too
it really does but I wanted them to take
it one more step and let them have the
cake again you can give us the happy oh
my god this movie is stunning but I
think you get why you don't get a happy
ending I know but it blows like it blows
like
cover yours if you haven't seen the
movie just give me 10 seconds of
spoilers all right ready
starting counting back then not [ __ ]
the bed
shishun come on that other dude how are
you marry another dude after Riga
because he shades amount of shades from
from that thing you do you marry young
John Hank you absolutely marry Spartacus
because I'm not taking anything away
from the guy who was the American
Werewolf in Paris
lovely [ __ ] dude but come on well
here comes the [ __ ] ah because because
in this film Ryan Gosling I'll break off
I'll break out of the movies and say
like I would like there are days where
like ice it must suck to be everybody
who's not Eva Mendes it would like you
Ryan God we dated a lot of mm-hmm
right like Rachel McAdams yeah to me to
not be with Ryan Gosling after you've
been with Ryan gosh I would imagine
would be like why live anymore and again
I hope this is we said spoilers so and
we didn't even well not them not too
much but you're getting the idea you're
figuring it out but yeah I felt coming
out of the movie like I get why she was
with Ryan Gosling because he does give
you something as a boyfriend I'm
assuming only Sebastian in this film oh
my god I was wonderful he's fun he's
like in everything you want except he
makes the wrong choices like he chooses
poorly well the way look let's be honest
the [ __ ] move was a photo shoot over
for one night oh we could just for hours
ah la la la land is is everything you've
heard and more you won't be disappointed
don't worry sometimes we've liked her
too much man it's probably gonna suck
no it's worth it yeah where's the
[ __ ] journey like they don't sound
playing on a selling an old [ __ ] man
but they don't make them like this not
anymore I remember watching the opening
sequence which you've seen a little bit
of in the trailers
but it said on this overpass in Los
Angeles stuck in traffic and it just
breaks into this [ __ ] glorious
triumphant musical scene I just I roll
the tear at the beginning we haven't
even seen a character we give a [ __ ]
about yet but it was just I it's been a
long time since I've seen a film so
confident so like we're doing this now
yeah and we're gonna you are going to
love it for what it is and you are going
to swing with it and you're going to
roll with it because everybody is so
passionate about what they're doing and
you just feel the controls like here's
the story I'm going to tell you it
involves singing and dancing and primary
colors and our [ __ ] giant goddamn
drums on the back of a moving truck and
flipping and bicycles and skateboards
and amazing I forgot the rule I just
think about the last 10 minutes it's got
a good left him they gave us three
movies at the end yeah I'm like one of
them I'll hold it with it good because
that's a glad you're live but man you
know in the clue pick your own ending
version of this movie there were two
that I was very happy with and they
could have lived concurrently or maybe
it happened like this anyway beautiful
filming any movie that can something
that unreal doesn't exist and we can
grab your heart and make you invest to
the people that are not [ __ ] from
real life and sugar that's the board's
work right there there it is that's my
top two edges got pending we're gonna
get the [ __ ] out of here man go see all
those movies when you can or check them
out you can see some of them right now
and video and iTunes go stream them over
your face neck and chest the first half
of that list is absolutely available
lots of that shit's available what are
you waiting for any weight or the real
surprise though is those I'm Tanya nice
guys we've got that on their list mean
that's the one that's the one anyway
we're done here you can put four fat men
on that amount of chips I'm mark barnard
comma watts another episode at some
point we'll go back and watch an old
episode whatever
no watch my top ten don't want to stop
ten and then I cut them together so I
can do that to remix it there you go
oh my god I already put it to a beep you
can stan is saying fast I'm saying fat
channel podcast calm or you too
calm / Kevin Smith
[Music]
[Music]